تخيل لو كان بإمكانك القفز على متن طائرة
في أي مكان في العالم في أي لحظة
دون التفكير في
التكلفة جيدًا، فهذه هي الحياة التي
سيعيشها ضيفي التالي. توم ستوكر هو
مستشار مبيعات وإدارة يعمل معظمه في
صناعة السيارات في عام 1990
كانت شركة يونايتد إيرلاينز  تقدم لعملائها
تذكرة طيران مدى الحياة لسفر غير محدود،
وانتهز فرصة
الاستثمار في تذكرة مرافقة، مما يعني
أنه مقابل السعر الضخم آنذاك البالغ
خمسمائة وعشرة آلاف دولار،
يمكنه السفر مع شريك في الدرجة الأولى في
أي رحلة طيران مستقبلية لشركة يونايتد إيرلاينز.
يبلغ الآن من العمر 69 عامًا، وقد سافر بالفعل أكثر
من 23 مليون ميل بالنسبة لتوم، لا يوجد
شيء مثل رحلة العمر مرة واحدة،
أحضر ذات مرة صديقًا
يحب الطعام الصيني إلى هونج كونج لتناول
وجبة وطار إلى أستراليا لمدة
ثلاث ساعات  حفلة عيد الميلاد السبعين،
قضى هو وزوجته أكثر من 100 شهر عسل،
لكن ستوكر لا يغادر مع
الذكريات فحسب، بل كان يجمع
نقاط الطيران والأميال على طول الطريق للاستفادة من
بطاقات الهدايا في الأجنحة الفندقية الراقية
والرحلات البحرية والوجبات اللذيذة التي كان يصرفها ذات مرة
خمسين  بطاقات هدايا من Walmart بقيمة آلاف الدولارات
في يوم واحد، حتى أنه
حصل على ظهور ضيف في إحدى
حلقات Seinfeld، وكل ذلك على حساب United's Dime مع امتيازات من هذا القبيل،
فليس من المستغرب أن شركة
الطيران لم تعد تقدم مثل هذه
الفرصة الباهظة، ومع ذلك فإن
الشركة تعشقه.  حتى أنه
وضع اسمه على اثنتين من طائراتها،
انضم إليّ توم ستوكر الآن في عام 1990، وكان هناك
الكثير من المال، أعني أنه يوجد الكثير من
المال اليوم ولكنك تعلم كما
تعلم، هذا شيء
يجب أن أفعله وأنا'  سأحصل على بطاقة
Companion Pass أيضًا حتى لو كلفني ذلك
500 دولار. وقد
حدث ذلك ولم يكن ذلك
أفضل استثمار بالنسبة لي فحسب، بل يعتقد الكثير من
الناس أنه كان استثمارًا سيئًا
ليونايتد ولم يعودوا حقًا، حسنًا ربما لا
بالنسبة لي شخصيًا، ولكن عندما باعوا
هذه التصاريح، عانت جميع شركات الطيران من
أزمة نقدية وما فعلوه كان
رائعًا، ما فعلوه هو القول دعونا
نبيع هذه التصاريح وبدلاً من اقتراض
الأموال ودفع الفائدة، سندفعها
بمقاعد فارغة لاحقًا  أعني أنني
أحب يونايتد، إنه أمر رائع، أحب
اتجاه الذهاب وكيف يتحولون إلى اللون
الأخضر للحفاظ على الجو نظيفًا
للجميع، لذلك أحب الطيران، أحب
الطيران وأحب الأشخاص الذين أقابلهم على متن الطائرات
وعلى متنها  الأرض هذا هو
الجزء الأفضل